sial le chef de l'état qui poursuit sa
série de consultations avec les chefs de
toutes les formations politiques
représentées au parlement européen de
strasbourg
aujourd'hui il recevait françois bayrou
un entretien qualifié de franc et direct
le président du modem a visiblement pris
un peu de recul après son échec de
dimanche dernier anne calme et au ski
cette poignée de main sur le perron de
l'elysée françois bayrou l'aurais
préférée au lendemain d'une
présidentielle victorieuse mais
aujourd'hui c'est un leader du modem
affaibli par sa débâcle aux européennes
qui s'est rendu au rendez-vous de
nicolas sarkozy une rencontre qualifiée
de franche et sans ambiguïté par le
centriste qui face aux caméras décidé
d'opter pour l'humour si je dois résumé
le climat je dirais volontiers que
j'avais l'impression qu'il préférait
être à sa place qu'à la mienne une place
de plus en plus inconfortable après la
défaite électorale françois bayrou
pourrait voir ses principaux lieutenants
passé au camp adverse
marielle de sarnez ou encore l'ancien
vert jean luc bennahmias aurait été
approché par la droite michel mercier
actuel trésorier du modem serait
pressenti pour faire son entrée au
gouvernement
l'homme en tout cas semble déjà prendre
ses distances avec son patron si la même
plus parler de l'europe ne pas faire
trop d'antisarkozysme primaire peut être
meilleur réseau
pour la majorité présidentielle michel
mercier serait une belle prise
un coup porté à l'autorité de françois
bayrou sur le modem un parti ébranlé par
sa 4e place aux européennes et dont les
militants n'hésitent plus à demander des
comptes